(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Getting back
with your X is acceptable.
Strongly agree, strongly disagree?
Answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our Kickstarter.
(upbeat music)
- If you had to rank
yourself against others
based on a specific
trait, what would it say
about how you see them?
And how they see you?
To find out, we brought
together five women
and had them rank each other
based on their dating profiles.
Then, five men rearranged them based
on how dateable their profiles looked.
This is Ranking.
- Okay, so I am on Hinge.
That's my favorite app.
My first prompt here is,
"let me introduce you to my alter ego".
This is a picture of me on set.
I'm like full glam.
Like, I don't normally look like this.
I'm a content creator.
I also am a model and that's
like a big dream of mine.
Got to let them know I have some friends.
And then my life behind the scenes.
It's a little BTS video that I made
from one of my photo shoots.
- A little booty, too.
- A little booty?
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit, you know.
- All right, my app of choice is Tinder.
'Cause I love this super like function.
I love to know that a guy's really into me
and therefore pursue the conversation.
So, my first picture is a
picture of myself eating,
'cause I love to eat.
And then I have a
picture of me with lights
'cause I'll light up your world.
A picture of me in this
like really risque outfit
'cause sometimes I like to put
on a little show for people.
I got a little too tipsy and
try to steal a cheeseburger.
So I just want to let them
know that even if I'm drunk
I'll still take care of them.
And then my bio says, "do you
have back pain, headaches,
stomachaches?
It's probably because you're
bending over backwards
and stressing over someone
who isn't feeding you right.
Now, with a new improved Gloria,
you can feel at ease again.
- Very interesting.
- Yeah, that was such a funny profile.
- Chaotic.
- So, I'd be like, what picture is next?
(everyone laughing)
- Okay.
Normal, regular picture.
Not my favorite picture
ever, not my worst,
but I feel like this is in
general what I look like,
and then this is my dog, Hasley.
Guess the backstory of this photo.
I just turned 24 on the third,
and I had all my friends
dress up as pickles
for medieval times.
Lots of people took pictures with us.
We're the same type of weird if
as kid you also collected rocks
and when they would break/crack
you held funerals for
them in your backyard.
- (in chorus) Aw.
And this is me falling.
(engine revving)
But I'm okay.
- So, my app of choice is Bumble
because I like to throw out
like my little pickup line.
If you had to choose what
kitchen utensil would you be?
And then they'll be like, oh a spatula.
I don't know.
Like what about you?
And be like, I wanna be a little spoon.
- Ah.
- So my first photo is just
kind of just a photo of me.
It's not my best photo.
It's not my worst photo.
- Good strategy.
- Yeah, I kind of look a little mean,
but I say, "I have a resting (beep) face,
but I promise I don't bite
unless you want me to".
- Oh.
- And then I put a little
like risque photo of me at the beach.
I was like catch the eyeballs
and then so that they can scroll down.
- Okay, so this is me on Hinge.
I don't smoke drink or do anything,
so people usually like,
she's boring for me.
- No.
- But I like to have fun, I swear.
"I want someone who is
passionately pursuing
their purpose in life.
Relationships come and go,
but what motivates you
to wake up every day
will always remain."
I put that because I feel
like sometimes I meet
guys and they're like,
"oh, I just like money or drugs".
And I'm like, "okay, but like, what else?"
And then this picture was from Halloween.
It's actually a trap because it's just
like a lot of booty meat out.
And if they like that picture first,
I'm like, I automatically
don't wanna talk to you.
- I like that strategy.
- So yeah, that's my profile.
(gentle music)
- Okay, I'm gonna go ahead and put me last
'cause I know I'm like
just a walking red flag.
(chuckles)
- I might go for the last
spot just 'cause I feel
like my profile is like kind of basic,
and also like Hinge gives
you a lot of prompts
to like actually really showcase yourself.
And I feel like, like with Bumble,
like it just doesn't have that.
And so I'm gonna put my-
- I'm gonna reserve
this one for me, but....
(chuckles)
- No, so I'm gonna put me right here.
- I wanna put my phone
down in the fourth spot
because I feel like you
don't know that much about me
from my page.
- I think a dating profile,
the point is to just give
like a little bit and
then they can message you
and then you guys figure each other out.
So I think you have a pretty good profile
and it shows like your creative as well
with your contact creation.
- But then you also need to go further up
because you have a lot
of conversation starters.
Like what are you doing your first?
- Yes, I do.
- Why are you laughing?
- I'm also true.
- All right.
Cool.
- Okay, okay.
Put this there.
Okay.
- Oh, you're the last one?
- My profile is so basic.
What are we arguing?
- It's not basic at all.
You've shared so many things
and like I know exactly
what you're looking for
from your page.
- I'm gonna make a switch right here.
Molly, you had such good
like conversation starter
that show like that
you've traveled so much,
and it's just like a
lot of your personality
in your profile.
- I remember things about your profile.
Like, I think you should
definitely be up here,
or higher a bit.
- Really?
- Maybe move...
I'm gonna move myself.
- Oh, why?
- At least I love yours.
I'm gonna move yours up.
She's traveled a lot, and
she's got have to share.
- Your page is fun and it's exciting.
And I am enticed to go on a day with you,
so that's why I think
you should be number one.
- Aw.
Okay.
(in chorus)
(upbeat music)
- Monica.
- Okay, so she...
Is she a model?
I Like to see her ina natural environment
with some friends, maybe a candid photo.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh, what the (beep).
- She knew when to plug it.
She knew when to plug it.
- All right.
Grace, 23.
- "I don't unless you...
- Oh-
- Oh.
- I respect the honesty.
- What do you guys think
when people put the Zodiac
signs on the dating app?
- It's one of these little tab things,
but if you go into a whole,
like soliloquy in the bio.
- I think the don't know yet thing,
that's the most out of all the tags.
- Oh.
- Don't know yet.
- Don't know what.
- I don't know-
- Like I think the boy you're looking for.
- The relationship.
Something casual.
- I think they're looking
for something casual,
but they don't want say that.
- Okay.
Gloria.
So here's my thing, right guys.
Tinder.
First response, honesty.
- Respectfully, it's a
little more short term, okay?
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Okay.
(everyone laughing)
- She stole a burger.
- So pocket burger man.
- That's the bio.
- Next is Molly.
Dating me will look like...
- What does that mean?
Look like her.
- Uh-huh.
- Best travel story.
- Getting stranded on
a nude beach in Mexico
when the boat run out of gas.
- I need somebody that,
like if there's a problem,
I need a solution.
- Guess the back story of this photo.
- Okay, that looks fun.
- Are they in simple outfits?
- Cucumbers?
- I honestly...
I didn't see your face very much.
Give me a nice, well framed headshot.
- Kristen.
- That's a lovely first photo.
- Yeah.
- Smile.
- I can see enough.
- You've got an outfit.
- Exactly.
- The key to my heart-
- The Instagram.
- Ooh.
- She's looking for followers and love.
- You guys see that as a red flag?
- That's a plug.
- I think that's a red flag-
- It's a little weird.
- Unless you're promoting your business.
- Right.
- Lot of far away pics.
- Happy Halloween costume.
- What is it?
What is the costume?
- It just says hot girl?
- Maybe she's hot girl some-
(upbeat music)
- Personally, Monica was the best.
She had a lot of different
looks in her profile-
- Clear, we have the the video thing.
- With a friend.
- And the friends.
- Well, just move this.
- So we're only swapping.
- See, she seems cool right here for now.
- She seems cool,
but as a Tinder, like we
are looking for dateable.
- So, you're saying everybody
on Tinder, can't be dateable?
- Well, here's the thing.
You can find someone like,
you know, a very lucky person,
but we all know it's a numbers game.
Guys are just swiping.
We're just swiping, right?
- If everything else is good though,
I don't wanna just like throw her away.
She's got a great diverse portfolio.
I'd say top three.
- But she does a lot of things too, right?
The Instagram.
- She has her Instagram bio,
but she says, "relationships come and go,
But what motivates you
to wake up every day
will always remain".
So, does that mean you're
looking for something seriously?
- So far away picks is
it's kind of boring.
I'm gonna say it.
- It's the pictures,
that's the only reason
and the Instagram.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Grace.
- Hmm.
- Okay.
- Well, I mean.
Okay, but if she doesn't
know what she wants?
- Hands if you think she should be five.
- Ooh.
- That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
- Sorry, Grace.
- We need to lock in these
two spontaneous girl.
- See?
Okay, but that pickle thing,
that's kind of cool.
- That is cool.
- I've never seen a pickle
that shade of green.
And are they avocados?
- I think we got it.
(upbeat music)
- Hello.
- [Man] Would one of you guys
like to do the formal reveal?
- Grace, Kristen, Gloria, Molly, Monica.
- Oh.
- [Grace] It's okay.
- Sorry.
- Questions?
(girls laughing)
- What was your guys' order?
- Obviously we're gonna
see first switching.
- Wait what did you guys put though?
Oh, can you guys like...
If you guys could stand in the order that-
- I think it was third.
- Like how is...
Is this number one?
- So one.
Yeah, one is-
- Okay, one.
- [Monica] I was third.
- Oh.
- I have a question for you guys.
- Of course.
- How did you guys define dateability?
- Okay, so for example,
collectively, we said that,
we think you put, "don't know yet",
so you're not sure what you really want.
So it's like why commit to someone
who's not sure what they want.
- But I didn't think guys
were gonna place that much emphasis on,
like my little don't know yet tag.
It's just because I actually don't know
what I'm looking for.
It makes me think more about
what if I had changed it,
would I have better
matches and better options.
- So we looked-
- I think we were thinking
in more long term.
- Okay.
- So we we're shocked.
- We were thinking like
just go on to a first state.
- We like real long term.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Like the girls were thinking dateability
as in like who wants to
go on a first date with,
and the guys were thinking,
like what is end game?
- Okay, okay.
Why Tinder?
We think of it as a hookup app, you know?
- Yeah.
- So-
- All the other apps, everyone's
like looking for something
and I just want to enjoy
a connection with someone.
- It's so funny.
- Our definitions of dateability
were totally different.
- And then we also thought
that you guys weren't gonna
care about which dating app.
- Oh, well we-
- All right, so you put
your Instagram bio in there.
Well, can I ask why?
- It's easy, because people
don't think I am real.
And I'm like, oh, here's my life.
- That's a good answer.
'Cause usually from a
guy's end, we usually think
either they're just trying
to get like followers,
or it's like, I've seen a lot,
like in the bio it's like,
"never on here, DM me on Instagram".
(everyone laughing)
- Wait, I have a question.
What apps do you guys
use for a relationship?
- Hinge.
(in chorus)
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
If I'm looking for a relationship
should I get off a Tinder?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Really?
- I actually hate dating apps.
I despise them.
I think it's very hard to
build a genuine connection.
For girls I hear all the time,
Oh, I want a beard, and he has to be tall,
and he has to be this, but
it's just like, go where,
you know, the person
who wants you for one,
and do they treat you right?
Do they treat your friends right?
Do they treat the waitress
at the restaurant right?
You know, like just go
where you're wanted.
(upbeat music)